i understand what you're saying senator
thank you
do you agree i i don't
disagree i i understand what you're
saying if
if something shuts down then uh
jobs can be lost and i i understand that
so thank you for sharing that thank you
guys on behalf of the administration
senator hoeven tribal consultation is
is mandated in in this government
and uh i would absolutely consult with
tribes when
issues are affecting them um and i also
would just add on uh senator that
uh with respect to the executive order
that the president
um signed uh it does not affect tribal
lands it just
affects public lands the the pause on
the leases
right
[Music]
senator i would absolutely if i'm
confirmed
asked to be briefed on this issue and
would be
more than happy to continue a
conversation
with you on it if we don't produce
uh
uh senator i am not uh i am not
altogether briefed on the environmental
standards of other countries
currently but i am proud that um here in
the united states that we have put the
safety and health of our workers
uh as a priority are you committed to
working
[Music]
senator uh it's my understanding that
president biden is
open to many ideas about how we get to
net zero so
um i appreciate
your ideas and look forward to speaking
with you more and of course
if i'm confirmed i'd be willing to work
with you
thank you appreciate it
thank you senator and next we have
senator
lankford sherman thank you uh very much
representative good to see you again
thanks for doing the second day uh of uh
questions with us
as well uh as you know uh we have 200
000 miles a petroleum pipeline already
in the ground
in america we have 2.4 million miles of
natural gas pipeline
already in america there's a
conversation about adding new lines let
me
th that's gone on here frequently let me
talk about existing lines that are
already there
generally would you agree that federal
agencies
should work with pipeline companies to
be able to
keep rights of way up to date to ensure
access to those pipelines already in the
ground
i thank you senator i it sounds
like um a reasonable um
idea okay in your understanding does the
department of interior have the
authority to deny
right-of-way renewals for existing
pipelines
that are compliant with all applicable
laws and regulations
senator where where where the department
of interior
is has the authority over such issues
they would absolutely be important and
if i'm confirmed absolutely take a look
at that
and do you think that the department of
interior has the authority to deny
an area where they have already an
existing right-of-way though to go in
and say that
there's an existing pipeline already in
this area as you know
there's thousands of miles a pipeline
that travel underneath federal
lands right now do you believe the
department of interior has the authority
to be able to go in and say you no
longer have right-of-way
in these areas and federal lands for
existing pipelines senator
uh of course i am not at the department
of interior currently
i i can't fully answer that question but
i would be happy to um
to speak with you if i'm confirmed and
certainly i'm sure the department would
be happy to
to give you an answer but do you believe
that the department of interior should
reevaluate
existing pipelines under federal lands
uh
again senator i i i can't answer that
question because i don't know what the
answer is
but uh if if i am confirmed of course
uh it's important to you i would be
happy to speak with you it's actually
important to every american that wants
to stay warm in the winter
and for everyone that flies in a plane
or drives a car it becomes a pretty
important issue
because if we lose access to pipelines
that are already in the ground
that are go through federal lands or
have right away we lose access
and what happens is all that energy then
goes to truck traffic
and goes to train traffic do you believe
truck and train
traffic moving energy is
safer than a pipeline or do you think
pipelines are safer than truck and train
traffic
uh i i again i wish i could answer that
question i don't know what the answer is
senator i haven't seen those statistics
i would go ahead and tell you that it's
safer and less expensive
to be able to move in the pipeline than
it is on truck traffic or in train
traffic
uh but let me let me uh we'll we'll talk
about that in the future uh
the goal of the endangered species act
we've had the opportunity to be able to
talk about this some
do you believe the goal of the
endangered species act is to keep
endangered species on the list or is it
to graduate
endangered species off the list i think
the goal
is to restore species i think the goal
is to work with communities to make sure
that we're
restoring those species um so that they
can survive
yeah we have a a wonderful little bug
called the american burrowing beetle
that is in multiple different states we
have it a lot in southeast oklahoma it
was declared endangered and threatened
before and we did a long study on it is
a bug that lives underground
and so we really didn't know what the
population was so for five years there
was a population study
on the american burrowing beetle and
after five years of study they found out
there are a lot more of those bugs out
there than anyone ever thought
and they're in a lot more places than
anyone ever thought and so for five
years that was the required study
it was the the number exceeded every
single year
what the standard was to be able to set
so it should come off the list
instead there was a pause to say but in
50 years
there could be a change in temperature
and if there's a change in temperature
50 years from now it could affect that
species
and so we're going to leave it on the
list as threatened
so my question to you is statistically
what do you believe
about how we should handle endangered
species if they achieve
all the population numbers all the goals
that were set to
delist them should we maintain all those
species to say
in the future they could be threatened
so we're going to leave them listed
or should they be able to graduate off
if they hit those lists and then
if in 30 40 years from now we start to
see a population decline
to re-list that thank you senator and
i know that um it's important to look at
the science when it comes to the
endangered species act and
um i know that every uh listing is
different
so uh what i would say is if i'm
confirmed i would absolutely
uh work with the scientists uh who
manage
these species and and absolutely
take a a good close look um i
appreciate um your knowledge
and and and caring for
um the beatles in your state and
look forward to working with you on that
um but
in the end it's i believe it's science
that manages that
i i do as well and when you hit all the
numbers and the targets that science had
set it seems like you would actually
graduate off the program
one more quick comment on this there's
uh leases
there's permits and then there's what
they're called sundries
these are the various items once you've
got all of the permits and it's how you
put the roads in just the decisions that
are made
typically those are made in each region
because they're they're the leases and
the permits are done
the sundries have now been pulled up to
washington dc with interior
to be for all those decisions that are
typically made in the region to now be
made in washington d.c my question to
you is
would you plan as the secretary to keep
those sundry decisions in dc
or would the regions be able to have
those decisions again as they have in
the past
um as i have said many times throughout
this hearing yesterday it's important
for local communities to
weigh in on important decisions and of
course i would take a look at that if
i'm confirmed but i understand
i understand what you're saying in and i
appreciate you raising that with me
today
so it's your hope sundry's decisions
would return is that what you're saying
i am saying that i i am not sure it
would
i i would have to take a look at it and
be fully briefed on that issue before i
could give an answer but i appreciate
the opportunities for local communities
to weigh in on decisions thank you
thank you senator senator cassidy
um
those families who just lost their jobs
because of the cancellation pipeline
which the obama administration's science
said
is
um
but nonetheless
[Music]
is
by the way
[Music]
but she
[Music]
and more understood to the country given
the conservation programs funded by u.s
energy enough
so
[Music]
we um from revenue sharing from
[Music]
activity helps fund our coastal
restoration which is
our adaptation
mr chairman a letter from my governor
and his assistant
and i'm going to quote a little bit from
my democratic governor's
letter we have a plan which will cost 50
billion dollars
over 50 years thereabouts to restore our
coastline
gomesa is the principal form of federal
funding to achieve this and
canceling leases and program paws
creates uncertainty in coastal planning
processes
having predicted 389 million in go mesa
revenue
over the next three years also
louisiana is entitled to nine billion
dollars of the bp settlement dollars
from the deep water horizon
we cannot access the we cannot access
those dollars
unless we have sufficient funds to apply
any lag or delay in go mesa funding
calls into question the ability of
louisiana
to realize the benefits of this nine
billion dollars
oil and gas production supports 85
percent
of our coastal resiliency program the
consequences of these actions this
political agenda
go against the science and the economics
of rebuilding my state and by the way
you mentioned that you have relatives in
houma louisiana
goes against the interest of preserving
their homeland now i just i just
i'm so frustrated by this and it's not
directed to you it's to a political
agenda which is so injurious to what's
going on
next let me also say there's been some
uh discussion about
from senator cantwell about the
greenhouse gas activities
associated with oil and gas but from the
obama administration
again the science if you will
that the eia says methane emissions in
federal waters in 2019
accounted for just 2.5 percent of
nationwide emissions that's from the eia
2.5 of nationwide emissions but
17 of nationwide oil and gas production
and when president obama's
administration finalized their five-year
outer continental shelf drilling plan
the eia
said that the greenhouse gas emissions
from the activities associated with
lease sales
would be slightly lower than not doing
lease sales
why because if we don't develop our
domestic
our domestic production then we import
from overseas
there's been several questions as
regards whether or not we would import
i would say that mr crookshank who is a
career appointee
at bone has testified in the house of
representatives indeed if we decrease
production
we do import and i would also offer for
the record
of mr chairman a letter in 2018 signed
by senators kent will
menendez schumer and marky
which actually asks the president
to ask opec to increase production so we
could
increase more oil and gas because oil
and
oil and gas prices have gone up so much
and so
without objection and senator your time
is just about
thank you not only do we have testimony
that it does but we actually have people
recognizing
that the shortage increases gas prices
and my democratic colleagues asking we
do that
even though the obama administration
says that if we substitute foreign
production for domestic production it
increases greenhouse gas
uh emissions this alpha close with this
uh congresswoman holland
i truly hope if you're appointed that
you're guided by science and not by the
president's political agenda
you may have faith in it but so far his
current actions do not give me if
faith in it thank you i yield back thank
you senator and senator hyde smith
thank you mr chairman and welcome back
representative holland
as in louisiana mississippi is a gulf
state
and one thing that's important to us is
the bureau of ocean
energy management and um
you know if you're confirmed i'm just
interested in knowing what your
priorities are for the bureau of
ocean energy management and the outer
continental shelf
thank you senator and of course i am not
there if i'm confirmed every single
piece of the department of interior will
be important i know that there are some
uh amazing career um staff
who have dedicated their careers to
ensuring that we're moving this
department forward
the first thing i will do is consult
with each of those bureaus to make sure
that i understand fully the issues but
senator as i mentioned yesterday too the
congress is a co-equal branch of
government
i i don't intend to uh
in fact i intend i should say i intend
to make sure that you are always going
to be part of this important
conversation
you know your state far better than i
ever will and i would appreciate
your knowledge and your consultation on
all of those issues
thank you um also we've talked about the
endangered species act
with the senator that spoke a couple of
sessions ago and farming
agriculture is the number one industry
in mississippi
one out of every four jobs is related to
agriculture so the endangered species
act to help us be productive
is very important and i believe it's
critical to
utilize it you know any tool that's
provided in the farm bill
to conserve endangered species while
improving the review process in ways
that lessen
the administrative burdens on government
recognizing the needs of agriculture
as well as the needs of public and
private rural
suburban and urban land and property
owners
and promote confidence in the regulatory
process
that affects us so greatly will the
department of interior
under your leadership provide the
resources to find a solution
to the endangered species act
consultation roadblocks for pesticide
review uh that sounds like
an important issue senator and of course
uh that would be important to me so
i look forward to working with you we
striking
the right balance working in
partnerships with folks on the ground
and certainly farmers
are absolutely important to this
discussion
and working to just find the solutions
that we need to to make sure that
folks can can work and and
sustain themselves and
one thing that i'm hearing from my
constituents
is that we know that the low income
households pay a disproportion
disproportionate share of their income
to overall energy costs for various
reasons
and since president biden's recent
executive orders restricting
oil and gas leasing and halting the
keystone
pipeline i continue to hear from my
constituents especially since we've just
gone
last week through an ice storm that
we're not used to going through
they're worried about their rising
energy cost and you know we had to use
different sources we had to use natural
gas when electricity was out
and they're very concerned about this
right now what is the thought process
behind restricting the u.s energy
production
as it relates to energy affordability
for my constituents
particularly for the low-income
households
what what's the thought process behind
that if we
are so sure that it's going to increase
our costs
to the lower income senator i
i think that it's important that
everyone
have the energy they need to sustain
their daily lives
i as you were talking i was remembering
my grandmother at mesita where i talked
about yesterday
didn't get gas or electricity or running
water until the mid 70s so
i i i feel like we're this is 2021
everyone uh should be able to partake
in those modern conveniences and
certainly not break the bank i
i know that um uh having
a diversity of
energy resources will certainly help in
times when we have
these these ice storms and and climate
events
that cause power lines and so forth to
go down
um and i i think that um i i
always move back to the conversation i
had with chairman manchin about
technology and innovation i think
um that we have a tremendous future
ahead of us
working to find the solutions for those
things i think
that if we work together to find those
solutions that
energy costs for families could
absolutely go down
and um and i i hope that that's the case
we have solar panels on our home
uh the electric bill is about ten
dollars a month
um i i wish everyone um had that
i think i know my time is out thank you
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much and now we have
senator sanders
he's not
i'm so sorry and we don't have said and
bernie is missing
we keep trying bernie so whenever you
show up buddy you're ready
how about senator marshall
okay thank you chairman and welcome
again congressman holland glad
good to see you again i want to start
off by talking about the endangered
species act
and my endangered specie is the lesser
prairie chicken but every state of
course has
one and i just want to share my story
about
about prairie chicken my my mother's
farm
is ten miles from cassidy kansas now
cassidy kansas is
called the prairie chicken capital of
the world for a reason
and growing up one of our rights to
passage was to go prairie chicken
hunting with my
dad and my uncles and i remember very
vividly 10 years of age
i had a single shot h r shotgun we
hunted saturday no luck sunday
no luck and this is you get up at four
in the morning and you go out and you
freeze you sit in the middle of a milo
field so i was pretty
distraught and we saw one prairie
chicken fly out into a prairie field of
our neighbors
and i told him i asked my dad and uncle
can i go shoot that prairie chicken he
said oh you don't have a chance
it'll fly before you get there went out
stocked it
and sure enough ten-year-old little
roger marshall shot a prairie chicken
his first bird and
i was a hero for the day we took it back
to the farm and
we had prairie chicken and noodles and
um we've seen the population decimator
that was a greater prairie chicken the
issue is the lesser prairie chicken
i was fortunate enough to be on the
wildlife parks and
the wildlife parks and game commission
there in kansas
and uh followed the prairie chicken
really closely
in 2013 it was at its nader and just
coincidentally 2013 was it was the end
of a big big drought
and as it started raining again habitat
improved and the prairie chicken
population is double of what it is in
2013.
and i think that's a story real common
you know that that
droughts cause wildlife to go down and
it rains the wildlife comes back
but as i really dug deep into that issue
voluntary conservation was the most
successful the government
projects were miserable failures but a
couple ranchers fifth
sixth generation ranchers i did some
volunteer grazing changes
and really were responsible for that
come back along with some some rain
so my two questions the endangered
species act
is how do you feel about voluntary
conservation in general and then how do
you measure success we know how
species get on the list but how do you
get off the list just in general
thank you senator thank you i love that
story um and yes i i am all for that
i i i mean we all we are we're all
stewards of this land
and and if more of us took that
initiative that those
uh farmers did that you're talking about
i think our country would be in a much
better place so so please thank them for
me
um i know that um the esa
is managed by science and um
i understand that um
you know we want those species to
recover to a certain degree i
um i want you to know that i will
absolutely pay close attention to this
issue
i know that the partnerships that you
talk about between states
between tribal nations between local
communities those are
very important for all of us to find the
solutions and make sure that those
species are there
so that your grandchildren can have the
same experiences that you have
you know absolutely that's the goal here
is those those great memories that we
can we can pass on
but and just in general though to push a
little bit
what would it look like to you for an
endangered species to come off the list
i understand we're
we're trying to follow the science but
there's
uh when humans interact with uh ecology
uh that's that's when the the conflicts
arise so what does it look like to be
uh in a you know proving the species
enough that they'd get off the
endangered species list
well i imagine that it varies from
species to species but
they i know species do need to recover
to a certain degree
and then i understand that you know
their habitat and so the things that
keep them alive as you well know
um the difference between us and the
animals is we have the ability to reason
and animals can only live by instinct
so they they can't live outside of of
their um their environment so um
i i am going to uh this is going to be
an important issue for me senator i
promise
and um and i will look forward to i i'm
not at the department yet i don't have
every single stat on the endangered
species list but you can bet that it
will
it will be important to me and to the
department okay i want to talk about
water rights just for a second and again
going back to my boyhood on saturday
nights
after we got all the hay hauled we sat
on the cellar and everyone would bring
all their stories
and from time to time you live out in
the country there's gonna be a water
rights issue and i just remember my
granddad saying three or four times
whiskey's for drinking water's for
fighting and i had no idea
uh queer at covira wildlife refuge is is
30 miles from my home
uh beautiful refuge a refuge that i've
had the opportunity to hunt
in and around it for decades as well um
and there's creeks that flow into it and
they right in the middle
of some really incredible car corn land
that we have to irrigate
and and thus there's the conflict
between the water rights of quivira
wildlife refuge and the farmers and this
corn growing is
90 percent of the economy for that
county 90 percent i mean i mean this is
important
these are the farmers whose babies i've
delivered the last 25 years so this is
personal to me
you know quivira has a water right of
course they do
and the the farmers have a right as well
quivira is a senior to it
but as i've seen through this drought
the duck numbers the geese numbers have
stayed great
despite kovira not using all of its
water right
that it's more you know thanks to folks
like ducks unlimited
that are providing better habitat up
north the ducks and geese have done
better the water shorebirds all those
have done better
does a wild does the the what the
federal
refuge have to always use all of its
water right why can't they share that
with farmers uh in a more equitable
friendly fashion i guess thank you
senator and i know that
uh water law is complicated and
important
and i know that there are water
attorneys at the department and
you can bet that i will seek their
advice and look at this issue
and rely on you to bring us your ideas
about how we can make things better
but would you acknowledge that the
farmers
are you exactly finish up finish up
i think i i think the far coming from
a traditional farming family who've been
farming for centuries and centuries
farming is absolutely important it's an
american tradition
i support farmers and would love to find
solutions to these issues
thank you thank you thank you so much
senator senator wyden
thank you very much uh mr chairman and
uh
congresswoman it sounds like it's been
another
long and challenging morning and
i've been at two other hearings but i
wanted to come back and
i know we're getting ready to wrap up
and i i just wanna
come back to some of the
fundamental propositions that
your nomination is all about the first
is
you get rural jobs that is
so important and i'm not talking about
this in an
abstract way i saw it when congressman
the goose
and i were putting together the 21st
century
civilian conservation corps legislation
and a chance to
create jobs for thousands of young
people in the woods
and scores of vendors could sell goods
and services
as part of that program and you didn't
just
say you're for being for jobs
you went out and you helped us actually
get
sponsors for the legislation why should
that not be a surprise
because you're kind of the league leader
in terms of
bipartisanship over there in terms of
actually getting
people to go along with bills so on the
track record
that we westerners care about which is
jobs and collaboration
the kinds of things i've heard you
talking about for the last couple of
days
is what i hear folks say they want
in my most conservative counties
they say they want more jobs they
recognize
that jobs and protecting our treasures
aren't mutually exclusive
that you can do both which you have said
and they sure as hell want everybody to
get together and collaborate
which you have made your calling card so
i think i wanted to ask
one more question about an
area where again you've brought those
principles
a question of jobs the question of
protecting our treasures
and bringing people together another
area where you put those principles
in motion and that involves both
water conflicts which we have as you
know
all over the west and
trying to deal with tribal water issues
which is practically every member
of this committee certainly all the
western members
have those challenges so give us
a little bit of insight into yet
another area where you're doing
good on the ground problem solving
and most of the members of this
committee are from the west
so this is not an abstract issue this is
the real world we see when we go home
and we have those town hall meetings
tell us a little bit about what you
have done on resolving water conflicts
and
tribal water infrastructure two separate
issues i know you have a good track
record
right thank you senator and what i'll
say is
um you know what i when i think about
tribal water infrastructure i'm reminded
just recently of you know a few articles
that i read
about people on the navajo nation uh
having to drive 20 miles just to fill up
some water barrels um some of these
people may
already have running water but their
water's polluted and i think in 2021
every single american should have an
opportunity to have
safe and healthy drinking water
this is a human right in my opinion
um and i mentioned earlier that yes my
grandmother didn't get running water at
her village until 1975.
i learned early on how to conserve water
because
when you're hauling uh buckets of water
across the village on a dusty road
you don't want to spill a drop of it and
i i think that
that we not one drop of water has come
into our left our
planet in 4.6 billion years
uh it's just that the climate change has
caused our water to move in different
areas so we need to protect the water
that we have
um i am all for ensuring that we can
come to solutions with tribal water
infrastructure
that we can look at water
in a new lens in 2021 when we know
climate change
is a drastic issue especially in the
west with the droughts that we have
and i hope that we can find ways to
conserve
recycle move move all of those issues
forward so that
um so that nobody is stuck in a desert
without
um any water to drink essentially the
confederated tribes of warm springs in
my
state and i appreciate the courtesy of
my friend
the chairman i'll just wrap up real
quickly they
are sure looking for your new lens
in terms of trying to deal with these
tribal
water issues and warm springs is not
alone i can look
right down this committee
and we see so many states represented by
this committee
who have these challenges with
significant tribal populations trying to
resolve
you know water issues and when you're
talking about tribal
populations by dint of that discussion
you get into the broader water conflict
you know questions particularly in the
west where there's scarcity
and as we wrap this up i just want to
make the case
again that we started considering your
nomination
really early yesterday i think
you had some of the same sort of
questions um
you know today we don't have people come
back
twice you know very often and i just
want you to know
not only am i gonna support you but i'm
going to speak for you
on the floor of the senate because i
think you have
made the case beyond the doubt
that you'll be there for rural jobs
you'll do it in a way that isn't
divorced
from protecting our treasures which is
in my part of the world
we want jobs and environmental
protection we see them two sides of the
same coin i think you get it
and i'll tell you the single biggest
difference
and i talked about these issues with my
friend senator mansion all the time and
all my western colleagues hear it
when we go home the number one thing
farmers ranchers and environmental folks
say they want
is they want people to try to come
together
they want to find a collaborative
approach
and if you're talking about that being
your priorities
you led the league over there in the
house of representatives in terms of
people coming together
and when congressman nagoose and i were
looking for somebody
who could help us we said we got a big
idea
really goes back almost to fdr
21st century civilian conservation corps
we said we need somebody good
who people like and want to work with to
go get us some health sponsors that
somebody was you
so i'm very appreciative and as we move
to wrap up the consideration of this
important nomination i want to clear on
i'm all in thank you in supporting
congresswoman holland and will
uh hopefully make get a chance to make
those points on the floor of the united
states senate
thank you
with that uh we have a few more
questions that uh we have senators that
would like to ask if possible
and then i'm going to maybe have to to
leave if i leave early then senator
barbarossa will continue
but right now we have a few i'm going to
i'm going to submit my questions
and i just want to thank you for coming
back and being
so diligent and and and doing such a
good job i really appreciate
congressman holland very much and with
that i'm going to turn
my time over to send a brasso right now
for questions yeah thank
you very much mr mr chairman we have a
couple of different things and people
have
these questions because we're very
concerned about our communities and
where we live
uh the jobs that are included and
related
and this major role that the department
of interior plays in the lives and the
livelihoods
of so many people in our home states on
february 4th of this year a couple of
weeks ago i sent acting interior
secretary a letter
which included 22 specific questions
about his secretarial order
banning oil and gas leasing on federal
lands and waters for 60 days
on monday the acting secretary sent
center response
which largely restates his secretarial
order
and fails to answer my specific
questions
so i'm going to resubmit my 22 questions
that will be addressed to you in writing
and be part of the hearing record
for this hearing now it's to me it's
unconscionable
that the people of wyoming cannot get a
straight answer from this department
and i know you're not in that position
now but there's an acting secretary who
is refusing to answer the questions
so can i get your commitment that you
will answer my questions as they're
coming to you
in writing yes senator
i appreciate that because i know the
staff at the department is going to help
you respond to the written questions
from all of us in the committee
and i'm confident that uh with your help
we can get answers to these questions so
thank you
i want to follow up a little bit we've
had questions about the endangered
species act
uh it's an important conservation tool
as you've said
uh that was enacted to protect
species from extinction the proper
application of the laws resulted in the
recovery of several species
it's important to me that the law be
applied in a responsible manner
so that we can protect the species that
truly need
protection yesterday when you were asked
why you would sponsor legislation
that would put the grizzly bears under
permanent federal
protection federal protection
permanently your bill in the house with
your name on it
you said i imagine at the time i was
caring about
bears well i want to make sure you care
about the law there's a law of the land
will you commit to doing everything in
your power to fight the frivolous
lawsuits
and d-list species that government
scientists
have concluded are fully recovered
thank you ranking member barrasso and
um i know that the endangered species
act
is extremely important as you said i if
i'm confirmed i would seek
partnerships with states with tribes
with local communities to talk about
this important issue
i'm talking about the law sir i will
always follow the law
thank you the global pandemic has
created an unprecedented situation
that has kept people isolated for almost
a year
one way that people have coped with all
of the restrictions from the pandemic
has been by visiting national parks
and public lands you were critical of
efforts to open federal land during the
pandemic
even though it was done in coordination
with state and local health departments
it's important to me that we are
ensuring that the public has a place to
go during
this public health crisis when there are
very
few other options will you protect
access to our national parks and other
public lands
during the pandemic
senator ranking member barrasso yes i i
believe now that president biden
is in office there is a mass mandate on
our public lands and in our national
parks and
um and i feel that if everyone does
their part to social distance and be
careful and wear their masks that
we will have more of those opportunities
yesterday you said you wanted to move
forward with president biden's
build back better plan that would as you
said
create millions of jobs in clean energy
your quote from yesterday
so recently john kerry claimed that the
fastest growing
job before covid he said was solar
technician
and he said that the administration
would give fossil fuel workers
in his words better choices and that the
washington post fact checker then just
looked into what
former senator and secretary of state
kerry had to say this is what the
washington post fact checker said
they said he was offering false hope
false hope from the administration with
a
with a misleading use of statistics the
washington post went on and said it
identified about
ten thousand four hundred new wind and
solar jobs over the
next ten years we're talking about maybe
a million energy jobs being lost in the
washington post says of john kerry
you're talking about ten thousand jobs
relative
to a million do you have any evidence to
dispute what the washington post has
said about the
statements coming out of this
administration and the false hope being
offered
senator uh what i can't say is i'm gonna
fight hard for every single job
i want people to work i know what that's
like
and i i promise you that uh
wherever i have opportunities i will
take them to make sure that people have
secure futures every family deserves to
have a roof over their head
well we've heard similar types of
rhetoric that we've heard from this
administration and from john kerry back
in 2009
under the obama administration and we
ended up with failures like solyndra
the promise of green jobs to billions of
ended up
with billions of wasted taxpayer dollars
bankrupt companies
and almost no actual jobs senator danes
thank you mr chairman mr holland good to
see you again nice to see you
um during the course of the last couple
of days
at ripon holland um you've implied that
you would virtually blindly follow
president biden
in his positions on energy and other
important issues for the west like land
management i can tell you
folks back home are really concerned
about the
the alerts to the left of this
administration
and uh if confirmed you would be eighth
in line succession of the presence of
the united states isn't the role of a
cabinet secretary to advise the
president
on these important issues not just
follow him blindly
senator the way i have always taken any
position i've had
is i feel that i'm part of a team and if
i'm confirmed
uh it's working with with all of the
other cabinet secretaries
as well as with president biden and um
acting as a team and of course as i've
mentioned many times
congress is a co-equal branch of
government i don't think we can
move these important issues um forward
by ourselves we need to work together
yeah thank you just the answers we kept
getting we're going to follow
president biden and i'm hoping you would
be a leader that would advise him where
you want to go
um and uh not just blindly follow uh
frankly his
his leadership right now that's moving
this country to a very
anti-conventional source of energy so
forth
i want to follow up with my 30 30
question you were the leader
in the house on that legislation um
it is president bind's initiative you're
also the author of that resolution the
house
um you clarify that you're seeking to
preserve
30 of all land including private land
what executive authorities do you have
and will use to accomplish that
senator i don't have all the details of
how president biden intends to move the
30 by 30 initiative forward but i do
understand that um he's hoping
uh for many different folks to work
together to achieve that
um i i was proud to um
support that i know uh your call your
former colleague senator tom udall uh
introduced it on this side of the
capitol um
it's the 30 by 30s number that
scientists believe
we should conserve if we want to have a
future for our grandchildren and
um i i feel like it's an exciting thing
to
to start uh talking about um
the possibility of achieving that so
there are
multiple environmental laws that guide
actions on federal lands as you well
know
nepa esa hhpa in what meaningful ways
do you believe our public lands are not
being conserved
uh well of course i i yes i know there's
a plethora
of laws out there that protect our
public lands
i uh senator i'd be happy to uh
take a a a look at that and answer your
question in its entirety and submit it
for your consideration
thank you you know um the usgs has
already reported that
30 percent of our lands are in
conservation status so
it's not clear to me what we're trying
to accomplish
um with that uh that resolution but
they'll look forward to having further
discussions on it yes i do too
um i know that my colorado colleague
senator hickenlooper wasn't able to ask
a question about the blm out west
moving the blm out west has made it
easier for montanans to connect with the
agency that manages large areas of land
our state nice to have them in the same
time zone
on march 10th of last year you said that
the department of interior was
attempting to dismantle the bureau of
land management by moving the
headquarters to colorado
why do you believe that moving the blm
headquarters to grand junction was so
wrong
senator uh i at the time i
heard from a lot of different
indian tribes quite frankly who were
upset about that issue
now that the blm the bureau of land
management office is moved to grand
junction
uh and and additionally i know a lot of
uh career staff
left the bureau because of that they
didn't want to move
um i think that we need to first
consider
the well-being of the career staff there
uh and take a good look at the issue i
i'm
i i don't have any intention at this
moment of
of changing things but i am not there
yet if i'm confirmed
that'll be an important issue to look at
so at this point then is your sense
you'd keep the headquarters there in
colorado i know senator heck would
probably want to ask that question
i'll ask it for him for the folks he has
he has spoken with
with me regarding that issue a few times
thank you
um i want to ask about some multiple use
questions it's very important our public
lands
in montana and across the west would you
commit to a no
not no net loss of timber harvest
on public lands uh senator i
i don't think i can commit to anything
at this moment i am
i'm not confirmed but if i'm confirmed i
appreciate
knowing and understanding um your
concern in that area and would be
more than happy to continue a
conversation
regarding no net loss what about grazing
permits would you commit to no net loss
of grazing permits
uh again senator i'd be more than happy
i i mentioned
earlier in the hearing that i understand
how important grazing is to
a lot of ranchers in this country and
and
they're they're very concerned they
really are as well as my
uh you know many of our men and women
who embrace the outdoors and shooting
sports would you commit to know that
loss of hunting
and trapping opportunities i have
support hunting
and uh fishing and uh i
support the outdoor economy i think it's
important would you commit to no net
loss of it the concern is losing it
losing losing uh
on a net basis we look at it there's a
lot of concern right now about some of
the you know your prior statements and
what that might mean to policy outcomes
and ultimately net loss of
of hunting and trapping opportunities
senator i
i understand and i promise you that i i
will
i will talk with you i will
do my best to make sure that um that
those folks have opportunities to have
their voices heard
so ross can i ask one more question okay
in the time thank you um if you put up
chart number four
and represent i want to i appreciate
your patience
um with all the questions you're
receiving here and i thank you
thank you for your answers um during our
meeting
when i asked you about active force
management
you responded that nepa comment periods
needed to be longer
and behind me is a map of a forest
project that was proposed by the rocky
mountain elk foundation
a great wildlife conservation
organization headquartered in missoula
montana
half of the project area burned because
it was delayed
by litigation it was in fact burned
while it was
middle of that delay do you really
believe that extending
the nepa comment period is the best way
to increase the scale and the scope
of active force management i'm not
saying that
extending is the best way
uh during our conversation senator i
think i was
referring to uh the idea of
public comment periods with respect to
for example
areas in my state where where folks
don't have access to
internet for example they were taking
comments only on the internet and if you
don't have
internet if you don't have computers
it's difficult to make your voice heard
i think what we need to do is make sure
that folks who
have opportunities and a means to weigh
in when these issues are important to
them
i'm not sure if lengthening that process
is the answer but certainly
make sure that the the public comment
periods are
are real when when we um look at uh
or senator murkowski and we've promised
how many we should be done at about noon
so that uh thank you
i i will i will yield to uh senator
markowski
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you senator
danes hopefully i'll ask a question that
will work for you as well
uh representative holland again thank
you for for your endurance here on day
two
um you in response to uh senator hyde
smith when talking about the issue of
affordability
this is a matter that is extreme
interest to me of course we come from
uh one of the highest uh cost energy
states in in the country in terms of the
rates that people pay
for for their uh for their power to keep
warm in a cold place and so this is very
personal
and your story about your grandmother uh
not receiving
uh power and water uh
to to her community until the mid 70s is
something that as you know
we still live in far too many of our
villages primarily alaska native
villages
um and and one of the uh one of the
bright spots
certainly for those in the north slope
communities is that
with oil those families have been able
to not only heat their homes but to do
so
in a way that is is more affordable uh
to not
only have the basics that we would
understand
in terms of staying warm and having
water
but also the benefits of a public safety
system the benefits
of of of transportation access the
benefits
of schooling and so i i just
ask you as as you as you look
to to the realities of of american
energy and how people are situated
that some of our most vulnerable in this
country
the the energy and vulnerability
uh is is a very real question a very
real issue
and so how we can help with jobs
and also making this this critical
component of people's lives available to
them
sometimes our reality is that it is not
it is not the energy solution to to have
solar in in utkjavik but the
opportunities that present themselves
with natural gas
um with with the base resource that we
have up there
is something that i just ask you to to
be
uh to be understanding of them
and and their situation i want to raise
also um uh the the situation
with with many of our uh remote
communities primarily
alaska native villages that
are reliant on so many of these policies
that
are in play right now many in this
committee have heard me
speak at length about the community of
king
cove a small community of 800 people out
in southwest alaska
cut off from a major
runway that can allow them an
opportunity to get their people to
safety when weather shuts them in on
average a hundred
days a year in 2013 the secretary of the
interior turned her back
on those people and said that somebody
needed
to be thinking about the birds in the
meantime
those people in king cove have endured
over
a hundred medevac since the time that
that life-saving
10-mile one-lane gravel non-commercial
use road was denied
and and our coast guard has been called
in for
multiple multiple medevacs to get these
people to safety
so i i'm going to ask you if you will
commit to at a bare minimum
to meeting with the people
of king cove to discuss their plight and
to hear
their concerns and do this if you are
confirmed
very early within your tenure senator
absolutely
thank you and thank you for for sending
me your memo
i i took the liberty of reading more
about um the issues in king cove
uh as you know i feel very strongly that
everybody deserves to have
medical attention when they need it and
i i appreciate you
caring so much about the people there
well i
am passionate about them i'm also
passionate about
our alaska native veterans who have not
yet received entitlement
to their native allotments we passed
bill
last year to help allow for that
processing but until we can get
these plos these public land orders
withdrawn so that there is an
availability of selection
it is it is they are being denied uh
their their entitlement to their land
their allotments and that is again
something where i'm very passionate
about and would hope that you would
understand there my time
is almost expired but let me raise the
issue
that uh was was just shared on the 30
by 30 and and your commitment
uh our reality is that uh
we've already we've already met the 30
percent
in terms of of our waters lands and
waters in conservation status
66 of all national park
service lands in the country are in
alaska
29 of all blm lands in the country are
in alaska
25 and a half percent of all fish and
wildlife service lands
in the country are in alaska 12 of all
forest
service lands in the country are in
alaska we have as you know
uh uh anilca an
alaska national interest land claims act
which
which pretty much established all that i
have
shared with you or or a good bulk of it
but our reality was the deal at that
time in 1980 was
we've got enough in conservation status
in alaska
we we are doing more than our share
more and we're we're happy we we love
our parks we love
we love uh the opportunities that we
have on our lands but we also
believed very much in the commitment
that the federal government made with
anilca
that the no more clause meant no more
and so that is something that as we look
at this 30 30
this 30 30 provision and the direction
that that president biden is is
advancing under this executive order
it causes us some degree of alarm
because
we have received no assurance that
anilca as we understand it and
as was agreed will be respected
as as this administration is looking to
put
yet more lands and waters in
conservation status i don't know if
you'd care to comment about that but
that again is a very
very important matter to us senator
thank you so much
i i i appreciate everything that you do
for your state
and i look i look so forward to
working with you i i promise you i'll
follow the law
i i i know how important these issues
are to you
and to the people in your state and i
look forward so you would agree that
with anilca and the and the no more
clause that's the law
that that what we have in conservation
status
will not be impacted by this 30 by 30
initiative i
look forward as i mentioned earlier i
don't know what that full
initiative looks like but i absolutely
respect everything that you have said
and i appreciate it and look forward to
working with you and uh and that i will
absolutely follow the law and
and thank you senator murkowski thank
you thank you mr chair thank you
senator heinrich i don't think i have
any more questions if we want to wrap up
senator marshall do you have a final
wrapping question
um just one
please proceed okay again
i want if you haven't been able to tell
yet i'm passionate about the great
outdoors fishing and hunting
hiking boating and i want to make sure
that my grandchildren have that same
opportunity the greatest memories of my
life are times in the outdoors
are you familiar with the pitman roberts
it's where fishermen
and hunters put our money where our
mouth is
yes i believe i am so again from my
experience on the wildlife and parks
board
i got to see where that money was used
but it's an 11
excise tax on guns ammunition and
fishing equipment
and in my humble opinion i think the
states do a great job of figuring out
how to spend that money
any thoughts how you think that money
should be used or not used
well what i will say is uh you hit the
nail on the head every time senator when
you say that
the local folks the state should weigh
in on these issues and
um and i i agree with you
on everything that you have brought up
today and certainly the fact that
uh we want your grandkids to have those
opportunities as well so
i i want to rely on you uh to bring your
ideas forward and
any way i can help i'm of course i'm
happy to
great do i get one more do we need to
wrap up
go right ahead okay i guess the last
point i want to make
is as we think about government policy
is it
its impact on that single mom that i've
been
delivering the last 20 or 25 years and
and the price of gasoline the cost of
electricity is so
important to them and our ecology our
environment obviously important to me as
well but
as i noticed as a private obstetrician
whenever the price of gasoline
got over three dollars a gallon and that
was just i was looking back through some
notes 2015
i noticed that those moms would stop
coming to their ob appointments they
many of my patients drive 30 60
90 120 miles so they so that's how in my
life i would see the price of gasoline
impacted people
and i think the the same impact is
overly felt by
by hard-working americans who live
paycheck to paycheck on their
electricity bill
as well are you concerned at all about
some of the policies you've described
what it's going to do to the cost of
gasoline at the pump and the cost of
electricity
uh for these folks at home senator thank
you for raising that
and uh that happens a tremendous amount
in my state of new mexico where we're
largely rural there's only one veterans
hospital in the whole state
and folks do have to drive a very long
way
um and that's one of the reasons why i
have been so supportive
of ensuring that um that broadband
internet is a human right
because i know that telehealth is a way
to help
a lot of folks with those issues so um
and we've seen that during this pandemic
if if folks would have had a lot of
would have had those opportunities
things would be different
i just want to say one thing i'd love
for you to look at
because you're a doctor the echo program
it was started by dr
sanjeev aurora in my state of new mexico
and i think you would find that a very
interesting
and beneficial program to our country uh
it's helped a whole lot of people
and and you can expand it in various and
sundry ways and i think you'd be
interested to learn about that
i'd be honored thank you and i yield
back
uh i look forward to uh i'll actually
put
a little packet together on project echo
because i i think our
our new member on the committee and
especially being a physician
will find it really interesting and
maybe even a great place where
we can all work together so uh thank you
all
for uh being part of this hearing today
and uh i think the hearing is closed
if i could just add members have until 6
p.m tonight
to uh to submit additional questions for
the record and i'd like to thank you as
well and
appreciate you being here both with us
yesterday and today
thank you very much ranking member
barrasso